le cancer continue de se propager, j'ai bien peur que
nous ne puissions rien faire d'autre, il y a
une personne qui pourrait aider notre
programme, c'est un traitement à deux volets
en dehors de la ville de Mexico, les résultats ont
été stupéfiants, elle m'a sauvé la vie
[Musique]
tu'  je suis entre de très bonnes mains avec nous
après ça que se passe-t-il alors toute ta
vie
John Kramer
d'après ces scans
la tumeur n'a jamais été enlevée combien de
temps ai-je des
mois au mieux j'ai encore beaucoup de
travail à faire
[Musique]
merci
bonjour à tous il est temps de jouer à un jeu
vous avez tous fait semblant de me tuer celui que j'ai
prévu pour chacun de vous est une paix bien
réelle
la seule chose que je n'ai pas fournie c'est
votre anesthésie mais croyez-moi
vous voudrez rester  alertez
[Musique]
parmi tous les hommes pour tromper que vous avez choisi
John Kramer, n'hésitez pas,
placez un morceau assez gros de votre
tissu cérébral dans le réservoir d'enzymes en verre,
cela vous sauvera la vie,
ce n'est pas une vengeance, c'est un
réveil
[  Musique]
vivre ou mourir, le choix vous
appartient